[Music]
Big Bird ventured out of his usual
neighborhood to celebrate at the Empire
State Building 50 years of entertaining
and educating children on Sesame Street
the television show is modeled on a New
York neighborhood and built on the
notion that learning can be fun while
diversity should be celebrated catchy
songs and goofy creatures from Elmo to
Cookie Monster are the building blocks
of its success and don't forget those
celebrity appearances we have
celebrities on the show because we would
like to draw in parents when parents
watch the show with their kids the
learning is deeper because you have a
conversation about what you watched
together
Sesame Street's appeal extends well
beyond US borders big birds a celebrity
around the world the children's show
airs in a hundred and fifty countries
making it the most watched in history
local characters often grappling with
local issues are what sets the show
apart whether it's zari an Afghan girl
who loves to learn in a country where
most don't go to school grown-up
problems or Carly an American whose
mother is a drug addict in a country in
the midst of an opioid epidemic my mom
needs help
it's the universality that all kids
deserve respect opportunity kindness and
a little bit of fun but married with
what's culturally relevant and what are
the educational needs of a respective
country put it all together and it's no
wonder kids keep coming back to Sesame
Street
Kristen salumi al Jazeera New York